And somebody in the crowd, I mean, it
was a crowd just full of as many high
school students as you could see,
yelled, "He's got a gun." I have never
run that fast in my entire life. I We
were crawling over people. It was almost
as if you dropped something in the crowd
and everybody fell over because you're
panicked. I don't know where this is
coming from. Who's got a gun? You know,
and everybody takes off. So, I I was
pretty surprised that people weren't
doing that there.
Welcome everyone to another episode of
LED Live. This is probably going to be
one of the ones that we've filmed and
put out probably as close as we've
filmed. Well, that's the hope anyway.
We're sitting in the studio getting
ready to release this a little bit later
in the week. But thank you for joining
us this Friday and thank you for
watching. Thank you for supporting us.
We're grateful and we hope that you
appreciate today's topic. We're gonna
delve into a little bit of politics and
some current events.
Uh, first thing though, we want to
welcome one of our new team members,
Felipe.
So, welcome Felipe. Felipe is Brazilian,
so he's got that nice
American Canadian.
Yeah, he's got that nice tan that we're
all jealous of.
I try. I try.
You know, he doesn't look like he works
in an office like the rest of us. And
he's tall. Yes.
It makes the rest of us look small.
Tall, broad shouldered.
Yeah. nice curly
hair. Setting him up to find a wife or
something.
Hey,
you never know. I mean, it's not like
we've not seen that in the comments
before
for our ladies. So, you never know.
Not me.
Yeah.
Off the market. The rest of us are off
the table. That's right. Well, it's good
to be here, guys.
Yeah. Thank you for joining our team.
Well, um, just the other day there was
an assassination attempt on a former
president, President Trump. Former
President Trump. What do you guys think
about that?
Dude, I was shocked, man.
Shocked. You were shocked.
I mean, I I just came home from a church
event and like uh our neighbor called
us. He's like, "Yeah, so Trump just got
shot." I was like, "Shock?" I was like,
"Is he dead? Is he alive?" It was crazy.
Yeah. I quickly um looked it up and and
saw a few things on it. Um I was pretty
surprised by people's reaction to it,
though. didn't seem like at the event it
was like as
Yeah. Everybody was talking about it. I
don't know. Yeah. I was kind of like
taken back by that I think a little.
Yeah. Usually he's like, "Get me out of
here." Right.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. What do you think?
Oh, it was it took me by surprise. I was
just walking down downtown and somebody
stopped me randomly. He's like, "Oh,
a random person."
A random person with the phone and the
video at hand like, "Hey, he got shot.
Did you hear that?" And
Okay.
And he showed me the video and it was
like just said, "Scotty, nobody was
moving." Yeah.
So, it kind of, you know, if it wasn't
for the picture, I wouldn't think he got
shot.
Yeah.
When in when I was in high school, um
our our high school ended up at um Six
Flags Magic Mountain. And it was like a
school day where all these different
schools from the local areas came and um
enjoyed the day. And somebody in the
crowd, I mean, it was a crowd just full
of as many high school students as you
could see, yelled, "He's got a gun." I
have never run that fast in my entire
life. I we were crawling over people. It
was almost as if you dropped something
in the crowd and everybody fell over
because you're panicked. I don't know
where this is coming from. Who's got a
gun? You know, and everybody takes off.
So, I I was pretty surprised that people
weren't doing that there.
But but there is the concept of fight or
flight or freeze, right? It could be
that people just froze. They're like, I
don't know what's happening. And you
know,
you got to process what's happening.
You have to you're like, what? You're
not expecting it. So, we have to come up
from that point of view as well.
Yeah. Fortunately for former President
Trump, he reacted fairly quickly and
ducked.
He was at least thinking. So, good for
him.
Um,
yeah, I I'm I'm kind of reflecting back
on the term that Obama was in office and
you know how and of course, you never
know. Is this news media coverage? Is it
is it more close to reality? But
supposedly there was like a school
shooting every single week he was in
office. M
and I'm and I was thinking like imagine
growing up being in public school.
Mhm.
Like it's the lottery.
You never know if it's your school going
to be have an active shooter that week.
I mean when I was in school I remember
training for earthquake drills, not not
active shooter drills, you know? That's
just like a crazy thing to think about.
Anyway, I was looking at some news
articles for this assassination attempt
and there was a word that I thought was
really interesting that would come up in
several of them. This one's from
Fortune. The headline is Trump
assassination attempt makes election win
more likely. Thought that was
interesting. And America's willingness
to use political violence may be the
highest since the Civil War.
I mean, think about what Felipe said.
You know, somebody randomly ran up to
him out of the blue and was like, you
know, Trump just got shot. Think of how
everybody did that wherever you were.
I mean, it was like all of a sudden,
what was on everybody's lips at that
moment? Trump just got shot.
Mhm.
Mhm. I was on um I was taking a boat
ride with some friends in the evening
and they had uh taking their boat by
somebody's house that also has a home on
the river and the person was texting one
of the ladies in the boat and that's how
I found it. She's like, "Trump just got
shot." And we were like, "What?"
Wow.
So yeah, it's one of those moments you
kind of you'll probably remember the
time and place,
you know, where you were at that time,
like 911 for those of you that were
alive during that time. You weren't
alive.
Hey, I was I was in elementary school.
I was in college.
Oh yeah, I was I was in my beginning
career stages.
That's everybody's ages at this table.
Yeah, right. Giving it away. But
multiple news outlets were actually
saying this. Um, the Guardian reported
political riffs have left the US haunted
by fear of civil war. And of course
talking about how France can do better
because they've had a lot of their own
political turmoil. There's a Louisiana
Illuminator. Uh, one inch from a
potential civil war. Near miss and Trump
shooting a close call for democracy.
Another one, the Scotsman. Amid fears of
second US civil war, Trump's opponents
must stand with him. Uh, very unifying
message. spiked an inch from Civil War.
Mhm.
There's no doubt that he's been a very
polarizing political figure, right? But
I want to take a a bit of a turn from
there to film.
Okay. How how are these two things
connected? You guys familiar with the
God's Not Dead series?
I watched all three Goss Not Dead
movies.
Okay. It's put out by a company called
Pure Flick. And Pure Flick I guess more
or less started or was one of the
starting companies in the Christian
media entertainment
Yeah.
industry.
Um
so they have put out um four and they're
about to release a fifth film. Uh this
is the first three. These are the uh
movie posters for the first three. What
do you I'm always interested in the
imagery that people display on their
movie posters. What do you notice here?
Looks political.
Okay. Very political.
It looks political.
What about this one? You think this one
looks political?
The one on the far right.
I mean, it's the church, but it's the
church burned down. So, it has to do
with religion from what I'm
understanding.
Sure. And that that's a very common
thing with their films, right? The these
current issues, current events having to
do with politics, religion, mixture of
both, uh, freedom.
Well, this is the fourth installment.
What do you notice about that one?
Political. Once again, it definitely
seems political. Like we're getting
closer and closer to the the capital,
right?
This one's called We the People. Of
course, borrowing that phrase,
makes it more political.
Yeah, it it makes it even more
political.
So, one of the co-founders of Pure
Flicks and one of the stars in this
film, his name is David um Ar White. He
was a he grew up actually in a minite
family
which I thought was very surprising.
He's actually put out a book called from
something to Hollywood. Can't remember
the exact title. It's it's on Amazon or
whatever.
I was reading through the first chapter
to kind of get a preview about about his
life. Grew up in a hardworking family.
His dad actually was a pastor in the
Menite Brethren. So, um, this clip is
from an interview that he did with Mike
Huckabe, also another US political
figure. You may re remember that he ran
for president once upon a time. And,
um, here he's talking about this um,
installment, God's Not Dead, We the
People, and why he is why he makes these
kind of films. My guess is that a lot of
this audience and a lot of our uh people
watching have seen the various uh God's
Not Dead series, three of them so far.
This is number four.
Um I think they've been brilliant and
they've told powerful stories that are
very much like from the front page of
the paper. So tell me what's going to
happen in this one without giving away
the whole plot, but why am I going to be
interested in this one? Yeah, it you
know it's interesting how um our goal
obviously with this when we started was
to make these films that would open up
conversations about God in different
ways and and the first one was you know
it took place in the college campus the
second was a high school the third one
reached into the community and um if you
ever saw that great movie Mr. Smith goes
to Washington. This is uh kind of a a
tribute to Frank Capra, but um it starts
just with this family and they're
homeschooling and all of a sudden uh the
community
um uh they come in and they start
asking, "What are you teaching exactly
to our kids?" And um and it basically
ends up they try to find the parents for
trying to bring God into the into their,
you know, curriculum. They want to
monitor that curriculum and ultimately
take God out of that curriculum. That
sounds pretty current.
I know.
I mean, that's really happening. This is
not a fiction thing that is going on.
So current, how current does that seem
to you?
And you have kids. I mean, you're not
homeschooling them.
Yeah. But
yeah, we started out in the homeschool
um thing, but yeah, if if if the
government was coming in and trying to
tell you, you know, you can't teach this
or that, that's problematic.
Yeah. I mean, we homeschool, so I I I
understand. And I mean that that
definitely resonate resonates with me.
So this is kind of their you you heard
it from him. This is kind of their
trajectory. We want to talk about like
current things that are affecting
Christianity. Very very cutting edge,
right? So this is the trailer for or not
the trailer. This is the movie poster
for the latest film.
I you know just just looking at the
imagery here. I mean it's God shining
down on the Capitol.
Um True. Yeah. There's like a cross
that's coming through the cross. Yeah.
And it's really associating these two
things of American politics and we're
bringing God back into the picture. I
understand. I get what they're trying to
do. In their eyes, this is a good thing.
We've left God. Look at how far out
we've kind of gone in the world. Let's
rope it back in and make God back a part
of our country.
But the question is, and I know this is
going to show up in the trailer, the
question is, do we then take away the
separation of church and state? Is that
good? Is it a good thing or is it not a
good thing?
Another thing too is in in the
observation of this as art, he his
character in the films is a pastor.
He goes by Reverend whatever it is.
And notice how in uh we the people, he
was looking at the capital across from
um the
it's an obelisk like the Washington
Monument.
He's like further removed, right? And
now imagery has him coming closer like
he's much closer.
So it's it's giving that visual of the
pastor closer to the the government that
that more union of church and state.
Mhm.
So this is the one that's about to be
released. So let's watch the trailer and
I want to get your thoughts on this.
Okay.
We ever forget
that we're one nation under God,
then we will be a nation gone under. Now
more than ever, Christians must realize
that we are being called to deliver hope
to a country that's feeling hopeless.
And a lot of folks have lost hope in the
future of our country.
We must maintain a role of separation
between church and state. Religion has
no place in the public square.
Once they bankrupt our country,
they will have complete control. The
preacher, he helped them education
hearings.
I've been hired to manage your campaign
for Congress. I'm not a politician. If
you don't take on this fight, we could
lose everything.
My next guest is a candidate for
Congress. You're going to get a lot of
questions about your faith. Well, maybe
people are looking for more spiritual
and moral leadership than Washington.
I will not be made a fool of. I won't
stop until your moral high ground
crumbles beneath you. I
feel like I have two options. I can
either do the things my faith asked me
not to or I lose this race.
God, we trust. This contest is about
shaping the future of our nation.
Reverend Hill, your beliefs are a
textbook example of Christian
nationalism.
Whenever anyone of faith promotes a
policy that you don't like, you label
them a Christian nationalist.
We need to stand up. Send the message to
Washington. Tell them you're not ready
to give that power up. You have the
power to change things. Not me, not him.
You. In God we trust.
And without God, democracy will not and
cannot long endure.
What I think is interesting and not a
very realistic picture is there are they
are pinninging the people that are
wanting separation of church and state
with people that do not believe in God.
Mhm.
That's not the case.
There's a lot of Christians who would
would say the state should not be
telling you how or what to believe. Mhm.
And that's the reason for the
separation. It's not freedom of
religion. It's not that we don't believe
in God or whatever. And it's like that's
that's this what they're pinning against
you is yeah, someone believes in God and
they want this. Someone that doesn't
believe in God wants this.
And also he was saying like, "Oh, but
you're you're calling everybody that
wants to do this, the combining of
church and state, a Christian
nationalist.
We have a video on Christian
nationalism, right? And I really believe
that Christian nationalism where you are
trying to basically force this kind of
religious beliefs. You look at partic
for example is is um dangerous. You know
it is dangerous because the Bible talks
about there's going to be a time of
forced worship. Revelation 13, right?
And so h how do you think people are
going to achieve that? How do you think
Satan is going to achieve this whole
thing?
Yeah. God, when when is God ever
forceful? Yeah.
Right.
Never.
He gives you the choice. And and I think
that's what is under attack right now is
it's like this sounds like a good thing
on the outside. I mean, if you didn't
really kind of know the beginning from
the end or what what's coming down the
pipe,
um this would sound like yeah, we need
to bring God back into our country. If
if you look at the history of the world
and forced Christian worship, we go back
to the dark ages, right?
And that wasn't pretty at all.
No. Exactly. So what happened was um the
um Roman Catholic Church was basically
um both church and state, right? They
were in charge. They were they were
subduing kings. Kings had to bow down to
the pope.
And you can find all this in in in
Christian history. Just look it up. So
the people were left in darkness. They
could not read the Bible in their own
language. It was always interpreted by
the you know cl R Roman Catholic clergy
etc straight from Latin. So they were
having spiritual darkness
and you see that the people who were
standing up to that system were were the
Protestants they were being mowed down
they were literally tortured for their
life for their beliefs.
Mhm. And so that's why the United
States, which was a country that lots of
people from Europe fled to to fight
religious freedom, said we are going to
have separation of church and state and
religious freedom. You can be Muslim in
this country, you can be Buddhist in
this country, you can be atheist or
Christian. It doesn't matter because as
much as I'm a Christian and I this I
believe that this has the truth, I
cannot force you as a Buddhist, Muslim
or atheist to believe what I believe.
Mhm.
But once you start combining church and
state
Mhm.
these people in this movie, they're
portraying it as that's when we have God
coming back in. But no, that's when you
have that danger that the fathers of
this nation have said no to no se no
state combined. You're bringing it back
together. You're against what they
founded this whole nation on religious
freedom and you're taking away your
religious freedom. But it's being
portrayed as religion comes back and
that's a deception. and Protestantism,
which is basically what evangelical um
you know, religion really is, is the
ones that's are calling for that union
to be. To me, that's the image of
But that's the thing. Do most Protestant
Christians understand their history and
why they're even called Protestant or
protesters in the first place?
I would venture to say probably not the
average. No,
I would say it's maybe a select few, but
that's why we're encouraging you guys if
you don't know Christian history, please
look it up because we're bound to repeat
it if we don't understand it.
Yeah. And check out our video on
Christian nationalism. We'll put a link
at the top and in the description.
So, in light of all that, not not
rehashing all the Christian nationalist
stuff, but I think this is important.
Um, in light of all that, there's been a
really fascinating comment made by Dr.
Kevin Roberts. He's the head of the
Heritage Foundation, which is the group
that drafted Mandate for Leadership or
Project 2025. I want you to listen to
what he says.
In spite of all this nonsense from the
left, we are going to win. We're in the
process of taking this country back and
we are in the process of the Second
American Revolution, which will remain
bloodless if the left allows it to be.
Interesting. So, can you explain quickly
what Project 2025 is for those who have
never heard of it?
Project 2025 is a conservative playbook
put out by the Heritage Foundation. It
covers every aspect of American policy
and how they would like to see all those
policies put in place. They have a roll
out timing of the first 180 days for any
conservative political candidate on how
all that would start to shape up. And um
it is known for promoting unitary
executive theory which basically gives
the executive branch a lot broader
political power which is very
interesting in light of the Supreme
Court's recent decision that Trump was
immune for official acts which I can see
that in some cases but at the same time
I still think every president should
have to abide by the rule of law. So if
you know he you can see how he feels
even more empowered now and if you were
to hand somebody over more power and a
Supreme Court decision that says hey I
can do what I want there could be a lot
of sweeping reforms in the government.
Yeah. And with Project 2025, um, one of
the things they have in there is to
bring back Christianity.
Um, and to have this what you could see
as the start of somewhat of a forced
push towards Sunday worship.
I mean, you can see just in their
slogan, make America great again, make
America pray again, make America
Christian again, or whatever. I mean,
the idea of making you do something is
definitely uh going back to the dark
ages religion.
Yes. And then Trump is also saying like,
well, we're going to give you Christians
your power back. I mean, and I'm not
saying like, I'm for this candidate, I'm
for that candidate. We're just
discussing what's happening in the
world. We're not against this or that
for this or that.
You're the people we want to hear from.
The pastors and the ministers and the
rabbis, the people in this room are the
people we want to hear from. and they
have to have a political voice. You
know, if you think about it, you have
men, you have women, and you have
religion. If you look at it, you have
more than the men, you have more than
the women. You have such power, but you
really, you weren't allowed to use that
power, and you're now allowed to use. I
get in there, you're going to be using
that power at a level that you've never
used it before. It's going to bring back
the churchgoer. I mean, you have to see.
I don't like the charts when I see
charts where they're going in the wrong
direction. We don't like that. We're
going to bring it back. And I really
believe it's the biggest thing missing
from this country. It's the biggest
thing missing. We have to bring back our
religion. We have to bring back
Christianity in this country.
And and they're saying like we will have
our way,
you know, with or without blood. But I'm
like, if it's God's will, isn't he
powerful enough to make it happen?
Exactly.
Why do we have to force it?
And it's you're putting it on yourself
at that point. Like I'm going to do
this. It's like what? And and it's
almost like look, the world has been
forced in a leftist mindset um to
believe a lot of things that are not a
scientifically true or you know that
really challenge the the the normality
of of of humanity at this point. And and
it's almost like we're just we're we're
just speaking on the other side of the
fence on this, but they're both doing
the same thing.
Yeah. What bothers me about this is,
dude, that was a threat.
Yeah. We're going to do this. It was a
verbal threat that's like we're going to
do it without blood.
Cooperate. There will be bloodshed and
violence. True.
And to me that's disturbing.
Yeah.
Um I don't think and especially in light
of what happened to to President Trump,
you know, it's that kind of language
that just incites more and more
violence.
I was happy to see that,
you know, uh as far as bipartisan
politics go, most people, I think
everybody was pretty much saying yes,
political violence is uncalled for.
Nobody should be doing that. So, at
least there's still a little bit of
sense in our country on both sides of
the table saying at least, hey, let's be
civil about this. You know, you want to
win, have an election.
Um, but of course, Trump being a
political candidate, you have this kind
of thing coming out. A lot of people are
asking questions. They're noticing. What
does he say?
This is from his account on True Social.
He says, "I know nothing about Project
2025. I have not seen it. I have no idea
who is in charge of it." which is funny
because there's a picture of him and
Kevin Roberts on a plane together, but
and unlike our very well-received
Republican platform had nothing to do
with it. The radical left Democrats are
having a field day, however, trying to
hook me into whatever policies are
stated or said. Um anyway, he he
basically says he he's kind, you know,
has this plausible deniability. There it
is a little bit bigger where he's like,
"No, no, no. This has nothing to do with
me."
But I think that they put these ideas
out there to see how people respond. I
don't think that they can can just have
chance. They've got all these plans.
They want they know what they want to
do. They need to know how are people
going to respond.
Yeah. Exactly. If people are going to
receive this or not and so they put
these really radical ideas. I think
that's why they put it all together in a
document and put it out there and just
like how do you what do you think of
this? And Kevin Roberts, he responded
recently in the news by saying that, you
know, I'm not surprised that Trump
denied this. He's like, it makes sense.
He's a political candidate. But that to
me just says, you know, I'm going to say
whatever I have to say, even though
really this is what I want. And he
admitted also as well, Kevin Roberts,
that Trump's personal policies and
project 2025 policies aren't really all
that different.
That's interesting.
That's why Trump would be endorsing it,
right? cuz it does align with white.
Well, yeah. And if you think about it,
right, like I if he becomes president,
which after the shooting, it's much more
likely that he will um if he becomes
president, then he has a huge huge
evangelical following. And there's a
huge evangelical group that follows
Project 2025 and endorses it. So,
I think there's a big difference of
being a Christian and being Christlike,
right? when you when we talk about what
does it mean to be a Christian and
follow after Christ, you know, like to
not have these moral defects basically,
right? I don't hear any of that being
spoken about. It's like, give me the
label, but I'm still going to continue
to do what I'm doing.
Yeah.
And so that to me is kind of a bit of a
um a strange thing that they're not like
discussing if we really want to get back
to Christian values, let's talk about
the the pornography that's rampant.
Let's talk about these things in life
that are think plaguing everybody.
And actually that is part of project
2021 is they want to shut down a lot of
what they determine to be moral
inadequacies in our country. And you
know, hey, I'm not for pornography
either. I agree with that. I don't see I
don't want to see pornography propagated
in this country, especially as it
relates to children.
But I wonder if that fuels the problem.
Kind of like the prohibition days,
right? you you say it's illegal and all
of a sudden this thing just gets crazy.
I mean, I don't I I mean, I I probably
have a little bit different view about
that because, you know, if you have the
power to do something about it and it's
wrong morally, I can see where, you
know, we should not allow it. Like,
you know, and you and and we've talked
about this, you know, especially when it
relates to pornography. There's the one
side that says, "Hey, it's a free
country
and if you're overage, you have the
right to do that."
But then there's the other side of it,
which is really dark, and you have child
pornography. Those kids are underage.
Mhm.
That's slavery.
You know, that's child exploitation.
And so, you know, if I was going to make
a determination, I would just say no,
let's let's not go there at all.
Mhm.
But, you know, that's me.
Um, what I appreciate you saying that
everybody should be open and honest
about it, and that's kind of what
bothers me about this a little bit is
here we have from CNN, you know, Trump
claims
not to know who is behind Project 2025.
and they did a review and found at least
140 people who worked for him are
involved.
I don't know how that could happen.
That doesn't look very good if you're
the leader and you don't know what the
your team is into. But yeah.
Yeah. So, it's it's kind of a
double-edged sword. You're either
totally ignorant about what's going on
or you're not being open and honest.
And I would just say just be honest. Um
but anyway, I wanted to get into a
little bit of the roots of where that
comes from. Um there were three an ev
evangelical leaders. I think the year
was 1985.
Um they were Lauren Cunningham, Bill
Brightite and Francis Schaefer. They
believed that they received messages
from God. And I don't know if this was
like dreams or visions or whatever about
um having a message to direct our
country, specifically the United States,
towards a more god ccentric uh
geopolitical landscape. And so this is
where the seven mountain mandate comes
in. It's the idea is that there are
seven mountains or seven areas. And
strangely enough, they actually tie this
seven mountain mandate to Revelation 17
where it talks about the seven hills.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah. Very interesting.
That's not what that means.
No. So, they it's in my mind, this is a
mislication of prophecy, but they tie
that to um this idea that we should have
dominion over seven areas. So, look at
this. This is from a a web archive
article. You can't just snag anymore.
But says the mandate proposes that there
are seven mountains that Christians must
control. Okay, must
must control to establish a global
Christian theocracy and prepare the
world for Jesus's return. So they're
looking at Christ coming back as
dependent on the state of American
politics.
That's very fascinating.
Yeah. I mean if you want to talk about
hill you would die on.
Yeah. And so they name what these seven
areas are. First one is government,
education,
media, arts and entertainment, religion,
family and business.
That's pretty broad.
All aspects of life basically.
I mean if you were to distill them into
seven categories. Yeah. That's that's
all aspects of life. So, um,
yeah, that's that's a lot of control.
And if you look at what Jesus is trying
to do, you know, it says in the Bible
that he comes when the harvest is ripe.
Mhm.
The harvest of what?
Right. The harvest of of people. And how
are those people ripe?
A simple way I think to think about it
is when you go to harvest like grapes,
okay, when you harvest grapes, the the
best way to tell if a grape is ready is
you take one off, you pop it in your
mouth, and you taste it.
Now, you can do all kinds of fancy
chemistry and and do um like a an um
what's there's some index
bricks or um
yeah, like a bricks index. It tells you,
you know, basically where it is on the
sugar scale or whatever and test it that
way. But the best way is just pop it in
your mouth, taste it,
Jesus knows at what point we're sweet.
Right? That's the easiest way I can
think of to to explain it. When we're
sweet, when we're ripe,
and I think there's going to be a lot of
sweetness in the individual, right? A
lot of kindness,
then then we're ready. Then he can come.
if if Jesus was really talking with the
disciples after he was um resurrected
and um he spent some time with the with
the disciples and he told them gave them
a commission go out and preach
repentance and remission of sin and
start with you know
the god's people and move outward from
there right
um that really is the true heart change
that God is looking for individuals
wanting to come to the table and reform
their lives and things that they
I don't believe that just because a
governmental organization tells you you
can't do this and you can't do that that
it's going to change your heart. God's
always been after the heart.
Always.
And so this gets really muddy because I
wish that we had God in all of these
things. I wish we were thinking about
that. I just don't agree with forcing
it. I just think that's going to be a
bad outcome.
Yeah. You know, there's a text that I
think people misapply in Matthew 11:12.
Says, "And from the days of John the
Baptist until now, the kingdom of heaven
suffers violence, and the violent take
it by force."
I've been in a church. I won't name it.
I have been in a church. I was visiting.
It was a non-denominational church where
this was taken with the idea that
Christians needed to take the kingdom of
heaven with violence.
Wow. And to me that was a scary
proposition like we need to take it by
force
you know and and now I look back and and
seeing this seven mountains mandate I'm
like you know this seems to all line up
when you have all these people that
they're making you know these statements
about you know it'll be bloodless if you
guys cooperate. That's kind of the idea.
But I don't when I read this scripture I
don't believe that it means that God's
people are supposed to be violent. I
think it's descriptive, not
prescriptive, if that makes sense.
So, in other words, violent people try
to take the kingdom of heaven by force,
but that's not the way the kingdom of
heaven works.
I um I I I find it interesting you
talked about the seven mountain mandate
um you know, and and the these people
that they call themselves the apostles.
Mhm. This is coming from the New
Apostolic Reformation which comes from
evangelicals. Um, and I had somebody
send this to me recently. This is a book
by Sha An uh, and I guess he considers
himself an apostle. Um, it's called
modern-day apostles. And there are some
interesting quotes here from this book
where he talks about this kind of stuff.
So, he says,
I'll read some various quotes here. Uh
it says apostles are the generals in the
army. Uh another one I believe we're in
that season where God is changing the
expression and understanding of
Christianity. When Jesus said he came to
seek and save that which was lost, he
was speaking of more than individual
salvation. Jesus was speaking of what
was lost in the Garden of Eden, the
presence of heaven here on earth. The
expression of Christianity shifted from
individual salvation to disciplining
nations. I mean, where does that make
you think of, right? Like the dark ages
like I was talking about earlier. I
mean, it's like remember when the
apostles, right, when when Jesus shows
back up after after he gets resurrected
and they go, "Is it now? Are we ready to
take it now?" And he's just like, "You
guys don't get it.
You don't get it at all." Like, this is
not the way the kingdom is won. The
kingdom was won by a calling, a wooing
back, a spirit that is working inside of
you to take to make those moral changes.
And so, yeah, it's like when you get in
this this space of like take it back, I
think we're on dangerous ground.
They tried to do that with Jesus. And I
had the scripture next, so it's
interesting you brought that up is from
John 6:15. It says, "Therefore, when
Jesus perceived that they were about to
come and take him by force to make him
king, he departed again to the mountain
by himself alone."
Yeah. He said, "Look, even when he was
taken and Pilate's sitting there going
like, "Where's your kingdom?" He's like,
"Look, if I wanted to, angels would come
up right now and force you. So, so
please, you know, don't think that I'm
here because you're overpowering me.
Right.
That's right.
Jesus did not get overpowered by Satan
and lose his life. Like, he laid down
his life so that he could take it up
again. Right.
His kingdom is not like the same type of
thing. And I and I just I'm starting to
really hear things in the media in
evangelical Christianity that's like,
"Oh boy, buckle your seat belt. Here we
go." It's like they're going to
literally force religion onto people.
And I think what that does is that robs
you of that ability to say, "I really
genuinely want to choose Jesus because
because I just I want to I want to
surrender my life to him."
Exactly.
Yeah. It's true. I I like that point of
view is that you actually take away
people's opportunity to have a genuine
relationship with Jesus, you know,
because you're forcing it upon them.
You stick a gun to most people's head
and say, "Do this." Uh, a lot of people
are probably going to buckle under that,
right?
That's a crusades.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean, the Muslims when they were the
ones in power, they were like, "You have
couple options. You can join us or you
can die."
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I mean, it's a very effective technique
to grow your organization,
right?
And we always ask the question, you
know, like what would Jesus do? This is
like something that everyone learns, but
then when it comes to that,
you know, it's like
interesting. You just don't see it as
the character of Jesus sitting there
making this call.
If Jesus was here today, would he be out
there saying, "Let's take back
politics."
Most people would think yes,
a lot of Christians probably probably
would. So,
I was going to bring this up a second
ago, but Trump's spiritual adviser, and
I forget her name, but in his first
term, she subscribed to the seven
mountain mandate. Wow. Information.
Wow. I'm nuts. So I mean it wouldn't
surprise me if in the second term there
was a lot more of that since this is
kind of where that whole you know
mandate for leadership type stuff comes
from.
Yeah. In prophecy, there is this um
beast power that is basically forcing,
right? That's why Revelation 14 talks
about, you know,
um he made all nations drink of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication, right?
She's forcing them to do something.
But then you also have this this
prophecy that there is a lamblike beast
that that speaks like a dragon and is an
image to that beast. And I think that
image is the forced do this or die.
You know, you see the same thing in
Daniel chapter 3 with Nebuchadnezzar,
right? He's denying the truth of God
being the sovereign after getting the
the dream interpreted. He builds this
image that looks just like him. So, it's
an image to him.
Mhm.
Right. And then he commands everybody to
worship the image.
Mhm.
Now,
in in doing that, you have all you have
all these people, and it's a it's a
little detail I like to really hone in
on, but you know, depending on the
version you're reading, it's like the
sat traps and the precepts and the
captains and all this
the music.
The music. Yeah. But all these guys that
are like or all these things that are
listed off, they're government
officials.
Interesting.
Wow.
They're government officials, the
sheriffs, whatever. So they're they're
all telling you it's not just the king
or the person in charge. It's all the
government leaders together saying this
is what you got to do.
Mhm. Mhm.
Cuz they realize that if you just get
the leaders to do it all leaders on
board. Yeah. And it goes back to that
idea um
from like Robert Caldini's book on
influence. One of the ways that we as
human beings behave or react to what do
I do in any given situation is
expertise. It's a double-edged sword.
Sometimes listening to experts is the
thing that you should do. You absolutely
should do that.
Sometimes it's not the thing to do.
You have to have spiritual discernment
in a spiritual situation
on how you're to react to that. You ever
seen how people use a uniform and people
will do what they say just because it's
a uniform. Like like ask them to do
really ridiculous things like walk on
the other side of the road here. Um and
if they do it in plain clothing, they
won't do it. you put it put someone in a
in a um a uniform, all of a sudden
people will be like, "Oh, okay." And
they walk like they'll do whatever that
person says. So, yeah, if you're a
leader and people are looking to you,
especially if you're a pastor. So,
that's even more interesting that you
just showed the God's not dead and
they're making that main character in
that story, a pastor,
pastor, congressman.
Yes. That he's part of of of bringing
that in church and state.
There's so much church and state imagery
in just that poster alone. Uh guys, I
think I think it's going to get really
strange.
Now, a lot of people point out, and this
is true, that the Constitution doesn't
mention separation of church and state.
That phrase is not in there, which is
true, but I think the concept is when it
says Congress shall make no law
establishing a religion, right? So, no
official religion, but the way people
like to navigate that is, yeah, there's
no official religion, but that what am I
supposed to do with my Christianity and
my politics? Obviously, as a Christian,
when you go to vote, you're going to do
it with the mindset of being a
Christian, right? And I think that's the
way it should be. It doesn't mean that
the way you see the world and that you
don't want the world influenced by
Christianity. It doesn't mean you don't
want it. We're just saying don't force
it on people.
Mhm.
Right.
Do I do I want to see certain ways of
doing things? Absolutely.
I'm not going to force it on anybody. It
gives the idea that if it needs to be
forced, you know, it's not something you
might want to do, which is not true. We
want people to be Christians and all
that.
But why do we need to force it if it's,
you know,
Mhm.
if it's actually that necessary to be
Christian?
God didn't tell the Israelites when he
took Canaan, make everybody else
Christian,
right? Or like Jewish.
They were going to share their biblical
worldview of God. But it was not like
make everybody like this.
Yeah. To me, if you have to force it and
it it can't stand on its own, it's not
powerful of enough an idea,
right? Jesus wants everybody to come to
him to want him, not to have him cram
down everybody's throat. That's not why
Jesus is asking. He doesn't care about
that.
If I be lifted up, I will draw all men
to me. So, it's like the the object of
us should be lifting him up and the
result of that should be people are
making decisions for God.
Yeah. And I and I find it interesting
that then we have, you know, like we
talked in the beginning, the shooting of
Trump where, you know, where's G going
to head? Is is this going to make him
even more powerful and um, you know,
influential and that he's going to get
voted in? And that's not the problem.
the pro the the the result of that
potentially likely is the project 2025
the you know push for you should adhere
to my Christian faith and and which is
obviously um pushed a lot by
evangelicals and the new apostolic uh re
what is it reformation whatever it's
called
you know it's crazy I was looking at
some data by Pew Research um And when
you look at people's opinions of the
political current political landscape,
they believe, the majority of Americans
believe Biden is more religious than
Trump is,
but they believe that Trump stands for
religious freedom more than Biden does.
Yeah.
Mhm.
And that he's more willing to give make
concession for for Christians. Mhm. I
thought that was kind of an interesting
observation, but
Trump doesn't strike me as somebody
who's like really like taking the moral
high ground. I don't know. He He I mean,
it's hard to look at them and try to
make judgment calls. We don't know these
people really. We don't know them what
they do behind closed doors, but I'm
just I'm just going to guess out there.
I would say both of them don't strike me
as such. But I think that you know this
is this where the Bible says that um
having the form of godliness but denying
the power thereof. Right? What's the
power of the gospel?
Right?
What's the power? The power is to make
that change. That's that that's the Holy
Spirit coming in and saying, "Okay, I am
morally deformed
and I need some reformation in my own
life and heart." And that power is you
turning into a transformation of a new
person.
And this I don't know. It's like it's
like we've got all the labels, we got
all the Christianity, but I'm not
hearing
the most important part,
the most important part. And that's
that's really this life change that
needs to happen.
I want to look at a story that I think
um really teaches a powerful lesson
about all this. It comes from Acts
chapter 5. And you know, after uh after
Jesus died, the apostles were very
active in Jerusalem and um making the
Pharisees like really nervous by the
things that they were saying. And they
got to the point where the Pharisees are
like, "We just got to take these guys
out." I mean, this is what the Bible
says. Acts 5 uh 33, it says, "And when
they heard this, they were furious and
blooded to kill them."
That was their solution to the problem.
We're just going to kill them. I mean,
they're gaining too much influence. Has
there ever been a disciple that said
that, "These people don't get it. Let's
just take them out." No,
never. Cuz that's not how God works. And
Jesus didn't do that either. Well, when
when James and John's like, "Oh, you
throw some fire, but that was before
their conversion." Right.
Exactly. Correct. That wasn't Jesus's
Jesus was still working with them.
Yeah.
So, it goes on and it says, "Then one in
the council, stood up, a Pharisee named
Gale, a teacher of the law who held in
respect by all the people and and
commanded them to put the apostles
outside for a little while." Now, this
is the same guy that Paul tutored under.
Okay? says, "And he said to them, men of
Israel, take heed to yourselves that you
in what you intend to do regarding these
men. For some time ago, Thudus Theodus
rose up claiming to be somebody, a
number of men, about 400 joined him."
Okay? He was slain, and all who obeyed
him were scattered and came to nothing.
After this man, Judas of Galilee rose up
in the days of the census and drew away
many people after him. He also perished
and all who obeyed him were dispersed.
Okay, so he's making a point, right? And
now I say to you, keep away from these
men and let them alone. For if this plan
or this work is of men, it will come to
nothing. But it is of God,
you cannot overthrow it,
lest you even be found to fight against
God. H
this is also I think a great lesson to
us that you just because people are a
part of an organization you cannot
dismiss them that God is not working
through them. I think that was divinely
brought out through that guy and and
he's part of the Phariseaic or Sadducees
or or whatever. He's a Pharisee, right?
And and so, you know, I I I think we
cannot dismiss individually people, the
organization. Yes, the Jewish were
denying that, you know, these men were
doing something of God. But, um, I think
we need to be really careful, too, just
saying, you know, evangelical
Protestantism is is off the chain. God
still has his workers in there and there
are still people that that God is using
to work through these situations.
Yeah. And I I think it it's a similar
story as you know what Paul went through
when he was still Saul.
He genuinely thought that he was doing
good.
Right.
I personally don't believe in part 2025
being biblical. I don't because again
the concept of force.
I don't think that God stands for that
at all. But that doesn't mean that these
people, these evangelical Christians or
other Christians who support this
project are not genuine and that God
cannot get through to them. Right?
God can.
God God has people in all churches.
That's why he said, "Come out of her my
people,
right? Otherwise, who would he be
talking to if it's not,
you know, people that he he can still
reach?" Mhm.
And in the reformation, those those
individuals that spilled their blood for
the kingdom that were martyrs and they
died, that happened so that the people
could see where this was going.
And they were able to make a choice. Oh,
wow. These guys are willing to just take
them out and silence them with death.
Yeah.
And there's no examples of God
necessarily doing that. At least I I I'm
not thinking of one that he would have
said that this is the method that you
should use.
Yeah. I I think the lesson here is that
God knows how to handle his own affairs.
We don't need to take violence into our
hands
to carry out God's will,
right?
We need to preach repentance and
remission of sin.
Yes. And so you brought this up earlier
and I I kind of want to like land the
plane here more so to speak. Jesus
answered, "My kingdom is not of this
world. If my kingdom were of this world,
my servants would fight so that I should
not be delivered to the Jews. But now my
kingdom is not from here.
Yeah, I find that very interesting. One
of the chapters here is talking about
that exact thing in in this book that I
just mentioned by this uh apostle I
guess of the N where he says like we are
bringing heaven down to earth. We're
going to make this the kingdom. But
that's directly against scripture from
what you're reading.
Yeah. I mean this the Christ's kingdom
only comes here after this whole place
is destroyed and the people are totally
reformed.
It's not for the here and now. And and
so you know Jesus in a in a very
powerful way is like look don't the
politics of the here and now is not
where it's at. my kingdom is is a
different place with different ideas and
and if you focus on the politics of this
world, you're missing the point.
And what Jesus by not engaging with
Pilate during this and pilot even saying
that that he's innocent was really
demonstrating that there's no reason why
this guy should die.
They're casting him because they're
scared of the crowd or they're forcing
or they're whatever. So, but look at the
position that we're in. It's not it's
not that Jesus, you know, deserved any
of that. And so, he's still wanting
people to see that it's still the
character that this was that this was
really about.
Amen. So, I think in all of this
discussion, we've realized violence is
not the answer. Violence against Trump
uncalled for. Never should have been
done.
Uh or any other political candidate and
any human being.
Yeah. Any human being. It's just it's
just not the way that God works. He
doesn't force his way. He's not violent
with people. So, it's all about
character like we've been saying. So, I
hope that you have realized that in your
own life. And if you haven't, um, you
know, we have some Bible studies that we
think can help lead you there. If you go
to lls.tv/bible
school, you can learn more about that.
You can learn more about the character
of God. Of course, you can reach out to
us through our website,
littlestudios.tv,
and contact us there. If you have
specific questions, we're happy to
answer them. Uh, if you want to help
support what we are doing, make sure you
go to um patreon.com or
littlestudios.tv.
Um, the short URL is lls.tv/g.
Uh, we encourage people to go there
because we get a a bit more of your
donation. So, uh, if you care about
that, then you want to go to our
website. Otherwise, you can find us on
Patreon. Also, go to lightwear.shop.
You'll find some cool shirts like the
ones that we're wearing. At least I'm
wearing one from Lightwear. and that
helps support some of the things that we
do here as well. Thank you for joining
us and we pray we pray that all of you
will be found with us in heaven one day.
We want all everybody to be there and uh
we pray that you will really press into
God's character and God's love on the
way. Thank you for joining us. We'll see
you next time. All right, I can do this.
[Music]
hungry.
There are conventional ways of sharing
the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things.
Um, never mind. A way that gets the
message out with confidence.
Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean?
Oh, thank you. You know, we're all made
with a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork.
Wow. Where'd you get it?
Lightwear. Wear your witness.
[Music]
Create your way Jacob
and he formed you, O Israel.
I will make him a pillar in the temple
of my God. And he shall go out no more.
I will ride on him. The name of my God.
Be strong in the Lord and in the power.
[Applause]
We shall mount up
like heels. We shall run.
But by every word that proceeds from the
mouth of God.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey, subscribe to Studios.
If you want to learn Spanish, a great
way will be watching our videos for
practice.
[Music]